one area where i think i could have done
a lot better is in the area of providing
clemencies
and pardons to
men and women who were over sentenced i
we did about 60 of them when i was
governor i learned some hard lessons on
the long journey i was in
for your listeners who don't know i was
the former governor of illinois and
former inmate number four zero eight
nine two four two four and needless to
say it was a lot better being governor
food's a lot better you don't have to
wait in lines and you get to sleep in
your own bed
but uh you learn a lot when you're on a
journey like that
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here living inside this tent for
100 days from november 20th to february
28th bring to you the issues and
awareness that you need to know about
the violence on the south side of
chicago but also to raise as much money
as possible to build a community center
on this much needed block called o block
it's called o block because it's named
after a young man named od perry who was
shot and killed the gangs took the o in
his name and start calling it oh block i
decided that we're going to keep the o
but we're going to change it to
opportunity block i want to thank fox
for giving me the opportunity every
single day to bring to you rooftop
revelations where i share with you my
thoughts viewpoints and opinions as it
relates to matters in chicago and across
our great country and every now and then
from this rooftop i get to bring you
some very special guests
today i'm grateful and thankful to have
a guest with us and we're going to have
some real true dialogue i can't wait to
do that but it's our former governor of
the state of illinois governor
welcome
thanks for having me pastor brooks man
it's cold out here it's cold and it's
getting ready to be a snowstorm so you
know we're gonna we're gonna
jump right in first of all i always ask
people what are you doing here what what
what brings you to the south side of
chicago on top of this rooftop well i'm
here supporting what you're doing pastor
and it's a wonderful thing and i want
the people out there who are listening
to know the great work that you're doing
it's all about creating opportunities
for young people keep them off the
streets keep them out of those gangs and
get them into places where they can do
constructive things like learning
vocational training traits
get a skill and work hard and get ahead
that's the american story that's
american dream the land of opportunity
but for too many kids there hasn't been
an opportunity what you're providing is
opportunity and hope and that will keep
the kids
off the streets and doing constructive
things and it'll have a tremendous
impact on reducing crime which is
clearly a big problem for us here in
chicago absolutely you know people are
going to ask me okay pastor why do you
have a former democratic governor
on the rooftop talking to you and
my answer to that is
when you were the governor
i was on the opposite side i'm a
conservative republican so a lot of the
policies that you had in place i didn't
agree with but one of the things that i
appreciated about you is that even
though you i disagree with some of your
policies you always allow me to talk
with you always allowed to have
discussions you always heard people out
and i appreciated that so i wanted to
bring you
and i wanted to hear you out i want to
hear your thoughts on some things and i
want to ask you some tough questions and
one of the questions that i wanted to
ask you is
you know those policies that we that we
talked about uh do you feel like
when you were serving as the governor do
you feel like any of your policies were
were wrong policies
well frankly uh pastor i
and this one probably won't shock you
don't surprise her but i really think i
was a great governor and a lot of good
things for real people care for all of
our children free public transportation
for our seniors for the disabled
but preschool for three and
four-year-olds i would not raise taxes
on the people even though my fellow
democrats wanted a big income tax
increase i wouldn't do it we move the
money around to make it work for people
one area where i think i could have done
a lot better is in the area of providing
clemencies and pardons to
men and women who were over sentenced i
we did about 60 of them when i was
governor i learned some hard lessons on
the long journey i was in for your
listeners who don't know i was the
former governor of illinois and former
inmate number four zero eight nine two
four two four
and needless to say it was a lot better
being covered
food's a lot better you don't have to
wait in lines and you get to sleep in
your own bed
but uh you learn a lot when you're on a
journey like that and by the way i
didn't break a law across the line or
take a penny was all politics and those
corrupt prosecutors did to me what they
tried to do to president trump but
having said all of that you learn a lot
on the journey like that and i think i
could have done better in the area of
clemencies maybe i could have fought
less
uh politically
but i do think that
there's a great opportunity to learn
from
the past and not to be stuck in the past
and take what you learn and try to apply
it to build a better future yeah do you
think you know that's great do you think
when it comes to policies do you think
that um bad policy
how does that impact communities like
ours when people put bad policies in
place from a from a political point of
view what what does that do
to communities like ours
i think one of the bad things about some
of the bad policies are the
policies that don't really do anything
for people they claim they do but they
don't they call them half measures
dressed up as solutions yeah and i hate
to indict my own party but too many
democrats today
are more interested in lip service than
actual providing real service among the
reasons why we have so much crime in
chicago and this neighborhood here on
the south side is so riddled by gang
warfare and gang crime is because
politicians haven't been willing to do
the hard and necessary things to provide
alternative
opportunities for kids to do things like
learn the trades yeah i can tell you
from my experience here in illinois the
democrat party in illinois that i fought
my own party over the issue of
vocational training for young black kids
young black kids were not allowed to do
vocational training in the trades in
illinois for decades and the democrat
party ironically was the one that
supported policies that kept black kids
out of those trades
and so i think a lot of what's wrong
with
our country today and here in chicago
and in the state of illinois
are political leaders too many of them
in my party the democrat party who
really don't want to solve problems why
because they want to keep a large
constituency groups largely black people
in a place where they're dependent on
them and dependent on government rather
than actually lifting them up and giving
them a chance to get ahead and not have
to look to government for their
solutions that's why vocational training
that you're doing for your community
center is so important because those
kids who can learn those skills and get
into the trades will get good jobs good
paying jobs they'll get ahead they'll
become part of the middle class and
maybe more if they start their own
businesses you know you break up you
bring up a good uh good question i want
to ask
how is it then
that the democrats can be so effective
in keeping blacks voting for them even
though
we both know you just said that there
are times when
the same black voters who vote
consistently for democrats
get taken totally advantage of and
they're not even given the opportunities
for for the party that they're voting
for how is that
i could talk about this issue for hours
we don't have that i know but i'll say a
couple of things first
what happened to black people in
american history is a terrible
tragedy it's the original sin of our
country and to this day we're still
trying to undo that sin so there are
very real
grievances that black people have by how
they've been treated in the united
states in our history slavery
segregation jim crows but equal
a lot of that had to do with the old
democrat party that was the ones that
were behind segregation and jim crow
having said all of that the modern
democratic party
they keep the votes of black people
by
doing a little bit here and a little bit
there but not nearly enough to
fundamentally change things and improve
things they make it so that government
becomes the only place where the
community can go to for solutions they
make it harder for individual enterprise
and businesses to grow and develop
because they're not willing to do the
hard things to keep neighborhoods safe
and as a result that a vicious cycle
occurs of dependency
which encourages single-family homes the
absence of dads in the home
an abandonment of the old and precious
moral values that are taught in black
churches which are so fundamental
and because of that because of the
grievances it's very easy to point
fingers and blame
rightfully in many ways other people and
so when you do that and you're so
cavalier about playing the race car
which is what a lot of the today's
democrats do
rather than bring us together but
dividing us rather than uniting us but
dividing us on the issue of race
it's unhelpful and it
pushes people apart doesn't bring them
together and it makes i believe white
america
a little less
open-minded about the real difficulties
that black america faces
and i think the disservice that's being
done today with this what i call
what's being called not by me but by
intellectuals
neo-racism
this new neo-racism that
is out there where
we instead of bringing people together
irrespective of the color of their skin
they're starting to divide people even
in our schools
racially i think that's going backwards
not forwards and it's done for cynical
political reasons because if you can
keep a community that votes 90 to 95 for
one party like the black community does
angry
at the other part of the community yes
you keep that big vote and it's cynical
politics and frankly it's immoral and
it's wrong absolutely no so with that
said if you what would you do knowing
all this what would you do differently
now uh politically
thought wise policy wise if if you were
still the governor knowing all the
things you know now experiencing all the
things you know now what would you do
because a lot of people don't know that
if you wanted to because trump gave you
a pardon
you could run for a federal office you
could run for president you could run
for senator you can run for congress
however in the state of illinois because
we're so backwards uh you could not run
for a mayor uh alderman or governor
because of our laws which are wrong by
the way if the president pardons you you
ought to be able to run for anything if
you got a pardon that's a whole nother
story
but
if you were in play what would you do
different what what do you think you
would do differently
i would reach out and try to
i'm glad you brought that up about my
about what i would do because that's a
very good question am i a democrat
governor or my republican governor
definitely a republican governor i mean
but what other party is it
look i think i think the american people
and i think here in chicago in illinois
pastor i think people are getting tired
of the hyper partisan politics where
we're so divided and that one side has
to be all for one thing and the other
side has to be all for the other thing
because neither party has all the
answers correct i do think that
today's democratic party is a very
different party than the one i was in
this is not the party of john f kennedy
this party's gone so far left so far
so far away from the values that have
made america great that i don't
recognize it so i don't think i would be
a leader along those lines i think i'd
be more interested in trying to find new
ideas and new solutions to old problems
for example
how do we do a better job of making sure
the police work with community leaders
and
regain the trust of the community
because they are necessary to keep us
safe how do we support the police as
opposed to
trying to defund the police or abolish
the police what do we do about improving
our public schools i went to public
schools here in chicago i'm a product of
the public school system i wasn't
exactly setting the world on fire when i
went there but i still was able to get
ahead and become the governor of
illinois but shouldn't we be thinking
about new ways to improve education what
about the idea of giving moms
and parents choices on where they send
their kids to school absolutely why are
we so stuck in that old politics in the
old way i know why cynical political
calculations i think people are tired of
that and the american people deserve
better
and they deserve political leaders who
are willing to step outside and try and
do things
and and attempt and find new solutions
to old problems and i think some of the
things that you're talking about doing
here with this community center is
exactly that absolutely so last question
so what what is the path forward you
know as we
we're up here on this roof
and we're talking about all the issues
in chicago issues that we're facing in
america what are we going to do what
what's the path forward
i think the path forward is a couple of
things it is
to live up to the dream of dr martin
luther king of creating what he called
the beloved community and that was a
community was based upon people who
didn't look at the color of somebody's
skin they looked at the contents of
their character it was a community based
upon love
and a community that was
predicated on a devotion to those old
and precious moral values that have
always been right and you can find them
in the bible and you can find them also
in other places but i think going back
to those kinds of things those old
values
fundamentally based upon loving one
another loving thy neighbor and living
the golden rule look it when i was
governor
and i hate to brag on myself pastor but
i got to tell you i really thought i was
a great governor i could have done
certain things better but i really think
we did real stuff for people without
burdening them with higher taxes and
when you do that you make the
establishment angry and they want to get
out and destroy you
but i would ask myself periodically when
i was governor i had that power that was
a beautiful part of being governor
what is it that i would want for my
family what is it that i would want for
my late parents when they were working
hard to try to build a better life and
give me a chance at a better life than
what they had what would i want for my
kids in other words in other words the
golden rule
if we
have political leaders who try to put
forth policies and offer solutions that
are predicated on the simple
common sense
yet i think indisputable correct path
the golden rule doing it to others as
you would want them to do unto you and
you have the power to do that that's how
we create the beloved community make our
country great again absolutely well
listen it's been awesome thank you out
listen we're going to it's snowing so
we're going to enjoy tonight we're going
to have uh some nice dialogue nice
discussion we're going to we've got a
little bible study planned then so we're
going to have a good time and i want you
to know i appreciate you coming to the
rooftop to share your thoughts your
points and opinions and
you're always welcome thank you pastor
brooks and i want to make a campaign
promise to you if that's okay i'm
sleeping over tonight but i want all
your listeners to know this ain't a one
night stand i'm coming back i'm
committed to the cause absolutely listen
it's been awesome uh i thank you all for
tuning in every single day to rooftop
revelations all the the people who view
our posts and send me so many nice
wonderful emails i want to take a moment
just to tell you how much i appreciate
it it's because of you that we've been
able to reach a broad
perspective and so many people from
across america and i want you to know we
are extremely appreciative here on the
south side of chicago
big thank you to fox for giving us this
opportunity every single day eli
steele's for producing such a wonderful
production
terrell for filming it even in the snow
and as i always say it's another day
another rooftop revelations until
tomorrow
peace
you